CHRISTOPHER WRAY, THEY REMAIN
SILENT IN THE SILENCE TONIGHT IS
DEAFENING.
HERE NOW IS ONE SENATOR WHO IS
SPEAKING OUT AGAINST ALL OF
THIS, FORMER
SENATOR MARCO RUBIO.
DO YOU ACTUALLY SAID THIS AND I
FOUND IT INTERESTING, DOJ, THE
FBI ARE PLAYING WITH FIRE.
>> LOOK, I AM HERE IN A VERY
UNIQUE POSITION IN SOUTH FLORIDA
SURROUNDED BY PEOPLE WHO COME
FROM COUNTRIES WHERE THIS IS
FAMILIAR TO THEM.
THIS IS SHOCKING TO AMERICANS
BUT IN LATIN AMERICA AND MANY OF
THESE COUNTRIES AROUND THE
WORLD, HERE'S WHAT HAPPENS.
A GROUP TAKES POWER, ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS THAT GROUP DOES IS
BEGIN TO PERSECUTE AND GO AFTER
THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS, AND
THEN WHEN THE SUPPORTERS OF THE
POLITICAL OPPONENTS BEGIN TO
COMPLAIN ABOUT IT THEY BEGIN TO
TARGET THEM AND CRIMINALIZE
OPPOSITION BID THAT IS WHAT IS
HAPPENING HERE NOW.
THEY TOOK POWER, THEY ARE
DEMANDING, YOU SEE IT ON TWITTER
AND THEIR PUBLIC STATEMENTS,
THEY ARE DEMANDING AND THEY WANT
DONALD TRUMP ARRESTED AND
CHARGED RIGHT NOW.
THEY WANTED HIM CHARGED MONTHS
AGO, YEARS AGO THEY WANTED HIM
CHARGED AND I'M TELLING YOU THE
NEXT THING YOU ARE GOING TO SEE
BECAUSE IT IS THE PLAYBOOK AND
THEY ARE NOW GOING TO BEGIN TO
SAY THESE TRUMP SUPPORTER'S,
THESE REPUBLICANS ARE VERY
UPSET.
THEY ARE SAYING VERY ANGRY
THINGS, WE THINK THEY MIGHT BE A
THREAT, WE THINK THEY ARE
RADICAL EXTREMISTS, LET'S START
ARRESTING THEM.
THE NEXT STEP IN THIS PROCESS IS
GOING TO BE THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPORTERS OF DONALD TRUMP OR
JUST CONSERVATIVES COMPLAINING
ABOUT THIS, ARE GOING TO BEGIN
TO GET HARASSED, BEGIN TO GET
LABELED AS POTENTIAL
INSURRECTIONIST AND ARE GOING TO
BEGIN TO GET HARASSED BY
LAW ENFORCEMENT.
THAT'S THE NEXT STEP IN THIS
PLAYBOOK, SADLY.
>> Sean: WE WENT THROUGH THREE
YEARS, THREE LONG YEARS WHERE WE
NOW KNOW THAT FISA WARRANTS WERE
OBTAINED USING AN UNVERIFIABLE
DIRTY RUSSIAN DOSSIER THAT WAS
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY
DONALD TRUMP'S OPPONENT IN 2016,
HILLARY CLINTON.
IN ALL OF THAT INFORMATION WAS
FALSE.
AND EVEN ANDREW MCCABE, THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE FBI SAID
WITHOUT THAT DIRTY DOSSIER,
THERE WOULDN'T BE ANY FISA
WARRANTS.
BUT YET THEY USED IT FOR TWO
TIMES, EVEN WHEN THE SUBS WERE
AS FOR CHRISTOPHER STEELE
ACKNOWLEDGED NONE OF IT WAS
TRUE.
THERE WERE NO HOOKERS IN MOSCOW
URINATING ON DONALD TRUMP'S BED.
THIS WENT ON FOR THREE LONG
YEARS.
I BELIEVE THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE AND FBI HAVE SQUANDERED
ANY GOOD WILL OR TRUST OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ESPECIALLY WHEN
IT COMES TO DONALD TRUMP YOU AND
WHAT COULD THEY POSSIBLY BE
LOOKING FOR HERE?
>> I ACTUALLY DON'T THINK THEY
WENT IN LOOKING FOR DOCUMENTS.
I THINK THAT WAS PROBABLY THEIR
EXCUSE, THEY FOUND SOME OBAMA
DONOR JUDGE TO WRITE THEM -- A
RUSE, YEAH.
THEY FOUND AN OBAMA JUDGE -- NOT
EVEN A JUDGE, MAGISTRATE TO
WRITE AND GIVE THEM A SEARCH
WARRANT.
I THINK THEY WENT IN FOR
WHATEVER THEY COULD FIND.
THE ARGUMENT AS WE WERE HERE
LOOKING FOR DOCUMENTS, WE DIDN'T
FIND THOSE BUT LOOK WHAT WE DID
FIND.
WHO KNOWS BECAUSE THE LAWYERS
WEREN'T ALLOWED TO SEE IT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE OBSESSED.
THE FAR LEFT WILL STOP AT
NOTHING.
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND THIS IS
A PLAYBOOK FROM ALL OVER THE
WORLD.
THE FAR LEFT BELIEVES THAT THERE
BECAUSE IT SO WORTHY THAT ANYONE
AGAINST IT MUST BE EVIL, MUST BE
CRIMINAL AND PUNISH SAM PUT AWAY
BUT THIS IS ONE OF THE REASONS,
PEOPLE HEAR THIS ALL THE TIME,
THIS IS WHY ELECTIONS REALLY
MATTER.
WE'VE GOT TO TAKE BACK THE
MAJORITY IN THE SENATE SO WE CAN
SUBPOENA THESE OTHER EFFORTS AND
WE CAN BRING IN THE DIRECTOR OF
THE FBI, THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
AND FORCE PEOPLE TO TESTIFY
UNDER OATH BUT WHO TOLD YOU
WHAT, WHO TOLD YOU TO DO THIS,
WHAT WAS THE JUSTIFICATION
BEHIND THIS?
THE STUFF NEEDS TO HAPPEN AND I
HOPE WE HAVE THE GUTS TO DO
THAT.
>> Sean: BUT HERE'S THE
PRETEXT, SENATOR.
--
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT APPEARED
DOUBT.
>> Sean: THE ARCHIVES RECORDS
ADMINISTRATION NOTE THAT IMPACT
DONALD TRUMP AND THE PEOPLE AND
MAR-A-LAGO WERE COOPERATING WITH
THEM.
THIS WAS FROM FEBRUARY.
>> OF IT AS A PRETEXT.
FOR WHAT?
>> NO DOUBT, THEY CAN SAY THIS
IS BECAUSE OF JANUARY 6 THAT
THEY THOUGHT THIS WAS A KEY WAY
TO GET AROUND IT, THIS HAS
NOTHING TO DO WITH CAPITAL STUFF
IN THE COMMITTEE.
THIS IS BECAUSE OF THE DOCUMENTS
THAT HE RETAINED THAT HE STILL
HAS AND THAT IS WHY WE WENT IN
HERE BUT WE DIDN'T FIND THAT BUT
WE FOUND ALL THESE OTHER THINGS
THAT WE THINK ARE INCRIMINATING.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY WERE
GOING TO FIND, THAT IS THE
POINT.
BUT LOOK, YOU KNOW THIS AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT WATCH THE
PROGRAM KNOW THIS BUT A LOT OF
AMERICANS ARE BUSY WITH EVERYDAY
LIVES, EVERY SINGLE DAY
PROMINENT MEMBERS OF THE LEFT,
PROMINENT MEMBERS OF CONGRESS
ARE DEMANDING THAT
MERRICK GARLAND INDICTED
DONALD TRUMP RIGHT NOW.
FORGET ABOUT THE EVIDENCE, THEY
WANT HIM INDICTED AND PUT AWAY
IN JAIL, THEY'VE BEEN DEMANDING
THAT FOR MONTHS AND MONTHS AND
MONTHS, AS HAVE MANY OF THESE
IDIOTS WHO ARE COMMENTATORS AND
THESE OTHER NETWORKS, SOME OF
THESE PEOPLE ARE SUPPOSEDLY
LEGAL EXPERTS AND THEY SAY
STUPID AND RIDICULOUS THINGS
ABOUT HOW THE LAW APPLIES AND
HOW IT DOESN'T APPLY.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHERE THE
DANGER IN THE FIRE IS HERE.
WHAT COMES AROUND GOES AROUND
AND HERE'S WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN NOW.
NOW ONE DAY THEY WON'T BE IN
POWER AND WHOEVER IS IN POWER,
THAT IS GOING BE A LOT OF
PRESSURE, AND NOW WE DO BECOME A
BANANA REPUBLIC.
WHO COME TO AMERICA TO GET AWAY
FROM WHERE THERE IS NO RULE OF
LAW AND WHERE EVERYTHING IS
POLITICIZED AND WHERE OPPOSITION
TO THOSE IN POWER IS
CRIMINALIZ